hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
we're currently refurbishing a house in
liverpool
this is one of my investors houses which
is going to be a buy refurbished
refinance
hmo i did a video about this a few weeks
ago it's going to be a nice
big three bed hmo right now we've just
been looking at the floor plans and
deciding exactly where the ensuites are
going to go
the toilets how we can add maximum value
once we finish the property so i'll tell
you some of the decisions that we're
currently having to face
let's go through the house so 3-bed hmo
you've got the first room front room
right here which is a nice
big front room now it's really really
important in 2021
that as as hmo rooms
if you want to get maximum premium value
you need to have an
ensuite to the bedroom so this room
doesn't necessarily need an ensuite and
the reason it doesn't necessarily need
an ensuite is because we could allow
this room to exclusively have access
to this bathroom now this bathroom as
you can see
is absolutely neat because he's being
ripped out so
we could have that front bedroom having
a bathroom here
now the only problem with that is that
the kitchen is on the small side and the
thing that really sells houses
right now is having a nice big kitchen
so what i
have recommended we do instead is
we take this bathroom out we knock these
walls down
and we have a big open space kitchen
with a utility area at the back now that
means that there's no toilets
no bathrooms downstairs at all it means
you've got a really big
open kitchen with a utility you've got a
big front room
but where are the bathrooms going to be
so what i'm thinking is going to be the
best way to add value to this and of
course it's not my decision it's
ultimately the investors decision so i'm
going to put in this to him today
but i'm thinking is that we have three
bathrooms upstairs
one ensuite and two off sweeps
i'll show you what i mean let's go
upstairs i'll show you what off the
suite is
so initially when this property was
bought i was thinking that we might be
able to have an ensuite in this room
however it's become apparent the bills
have told me that that's not really
possible and the reason is is because
the waste
like in other words the poo has to go
somewhere and it has to go out the back
and to have a waste pipe going from this
room
to the back means that the waste pipes
are going to have to
go through the stairs go through the
lounge in the living room
it's really not ideal so this room
is going to have an off suite and the
off switch
is going to be through here so this
bedroom sorry guys
this bedroom this this is a small
bedroom we're going to turn this
this is what i'm thinking have an
off-suite here
move the boiler downstairs have an
off-suite
corridor second off suite for the room
downstairs
and then have an ensuite
here for this room right here so that
way you'll have a really big kitchen
a nice utility space two off suites
and ensuite three double bedrooms and um
i think that's gonna give the best value
so
i'm excited this has just been knocked
down how you guys thinking about the
house
these these guys have been here all week
so they're
working hard next phase is going to be
electricians
plumbers we've already got the carpet
fixers we've booked the carpet fitters
so this this whole thing needs to be
finished by march time
so fingers crossed by march time the
house is gonna be completely ready to go
we're gonna get tenants in it we're
gonna refinance it and it'll be a
project
[Music]
done
[Music]
you